the Barbary macaques habitat is under
threat deforestation is underway in the
rif mountains of northern Morocco
declare the way for farmland we're in
beauchamp forests where the habitat
still looks intact wildlife
conservationists and waters tells us the
mckeaf then did relatively well here and
sold us hope of spotting some you this
is a small committed team of less than
10 people Mohammed choose one is one of
them he gets closest to the shy
creatures who Mercator horny-handed the
macaques come along with me so I'm never
afraid at night and in the morning I
find them waiting for me the same thing
in the evening till they go to sleep we
protect each other like friends hello
hello instead of me for a long time
shepherds in watch em forest hunter at
the Marquis sometimes to sell them but
the number of shepherds have now been
persuaded to stop good good let's go
there in the Conservation training
center see on shows us photos
documenting the illegal trade in barbri
Makino pesci we already work the
forestry authorities to confiscate
illegally helmick acts some of those
animals we you we look at very carefully
to see if they can be released back into
the wild so if we could have some kind
of building here a very basic structure
where we could assess their behavior and
their suitability for release that would
make life a lot easier for us because at
the moment we don't have that the remote
village of talamein lies in watch and
forests it only became accessible by
dirt track a year and half ago time
almost seems to have stood still here
but the village is slowly changing
there's now a small Center where women
can learn reading and arithmetic on
knitting and sewing
protecting the McKees is not a priority
here so Sam waters recedes carefully she
makes square that the villages needs
will be taken into account she explains
not only why her teens wants to protect
the McKees but also how it will benefit
the resident of talamein baroda yeah we
need to understand how the people will
share the macaques habit of our use the
forest see them attacks because they
don't necessarily see them within
tribute as the same way as we do in from
Europe from Europe so for example they
might not see them as interesting or
beautiful in themselves they may see
them as an economic resource or a pest
for example we still haven't given up
hope of seeing wild babri McKinney's the
next day we start up again and we're in
luck 20 to 30 meters away from us we
discover one lucky after another we keep
our distance so we won't scare them away